hey while you're here don't forget to
check out our brand new online store we
have original designs like this chick
magnet deku got a smashing mall shirt
created by pro artist Cuusoo mati you
can't find these designs anywhere else
so check us out at anime out Broadcom
link in the description what is up
everybody its Anna Mak here for anime
uproar and today I will be explaining
the most recent developments in the boku
no hero story including the mysterious
vanishing of the heroes as well as the
deadly plan that shigaraki Inoue gqo
have just set into motion the biggest
war arc in the history of boku no hero
is here the battles in this arc will be
epic and the stakes are higher than ever
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and Detroit
smash that notification bell you could
also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime out Pro for all the
latest boku no hero news and updates and
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the very latest
chapters of the stories so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so the three months time skip
from the previous chapter didn't last
very long because chapter 2 5 8 starts
off with a flashback to two months
earlier this is about a month after most
of the events in chapter 2 57 took place
aside from those few final pages as the
paranormal Liberation Front prepares
their assault on the hero society twice
is a bit confused about how to explain
the ideology of liberation to others he
asks Hawkes to help him out because as
the boss of the liberation fronts
tactical unit twice is expected to
understand the ideology but he is
clearly confused and he also has to take
a dump
apparently the Liberation Front has been
divided into several units and Hawkes
has been gathering information on all of
them along with the tactical force led
by twice there is also the raid regiment
led by gettin' and dobby the Intel
division led by
Tolga and Tamiya sue and the support
unit led by spinner and mr. compress I
can definitely understand why Dobby and
get-and would be in the raid unit their
powerful offensive quirks make them the
ideal attackers and of course it makes
perfect sense that toga is in the
Intelligence Unit since her stealthy
cleric allows her to move about
undetected and gather valuable
intelligence anyway as he reflects on
the liberation fronts current structure
Hawkes thinks to himself that if the
Liberation Front is allowed to make the
first move it will all be over the
villains are now extremely powerful they
have huge numbers and they have
infiltrated important positions of power
if the heroes sit back and do nothing
the Liberation Front will eventually
deal a devastating blow to the hero
society as a whole
Hawks is glad that he's been able to
gather all this useful Intel without
being caught but he has definitely
noticed that a lot of the members of the
Liberation Front Harbor large amounts of
hatred and resentment towards the
current system there is just so much
hatred for the hero society among them
and that hatred makes the members of the
paranormal Liberation Front highly
motivated and loyal to their cause back
in the world outside of his own thoughts
Hawks tells twice to just tell people
that the liberation fronts goal is to
smash the current society because it has
trampled on the individual liberties of
Quirk users and Hawks tells him also to
throw something in about Reed s trove
since he was the one who united the
front into what it is now
why says that he isn't really feeling
the reed estro part because that's not
really coming from his heart but he
concludes that he just needs to keep it
simple and butter everyone up as twice
thanks Hawks for explaining things again
Hawks reflects on the liberation France
plans they want to destroy the current
social system and annihilate the heroes
they plan to attack major cities all
across the nation and when the cities
are thrown into chaos and become lawless
Reed estriol plans to have his party
leaders take control since Japan will be
engulfed in violence crime and chaos as
a result of deliberation armies attacks
the people of Japan will desperately cry
out for some semblance of peace and
order when they see that the current
laws and the current society have been
unable to protect them they will lose
faith in these laws and in this society
Rhee Destro's people will then swoop in
offer relief and order to the people and
the people will accept them because they
will have no alternative and so the
paranormal Liberation Front will take
over Japan and things will return to the
way they were back when all-4-one was at
the very height of his power as twice
leaves Hawkes thinks about something
that I think all of us have been
thinking along with him when twice
overcame his trauma and learned to
unlock the full potential of his quark
double he went from being a minor
villain to the guy that Hawks has to
watch out for the most the power of
twice as quark became so much stronger
than it was before
that it is hard to even compare and
whatsmore
hawks points out that overall twice is a
good-hearted person despite being a
villain this means that twice will be
fiercely loyal to his friends no matter
what he will not sell them out for his
own interests hawks things back to a
previous conversation that he had with
twice a conversation in which twice
asked Hawks how as a pro hero he can
understand the Liberation Front ideology
Hawks responds by saying that the world
which he had longed for in the past
turned out to be a cage that made him
feel trapped
Hawks wants to fly freely and he doesn't
belong in a world that wants to restrict
his freedom and cage his soaring spirit
twice then says that he really wishes
that he could take hawks to see
shigaraki and when Hawks asks why he
cannot meet him yet twice casually
reveals that she got rocky is busy
powering up in the mountains of Kyoto
and that he will be doing so for the
next four months so it appears that this
past conversation took place around the
time that she gerak he first began his
powering up procedure with Yuko Twice
says that Hawks is really working hard
and going the extra mile for their
collective dream and he believes that
Hawks deserves to meet shigaraki after
all Hawks helps his companions
including twice himself so that means
that Hawks can't possibly be a bad guy
Hawks is moved by this and he seems to
really have a soft spot for twice this
is because twice values and appreciates
his comrades and he is very grateful
whenever his comrades go out of their
way to help him as Hawks has been doing
by teaching him about the liberation
fronts ideology and so on but there
might be more to twice as interactions
with Hawks
something that Hawks won't realize until
it's too late but I'll talk about that
later on in the video we then jump to a
scene with a whole bunch of heroes
including the top-ranked heroes like
endeavor the rabbit hero mirko the
dragon hero to UQ and the legendary
laundry hero wash and we could see that
even UA teachers like Aizawa present mic
space hero 13 and ectoplasm are all
there along with many others all of
these heroes dozens if not hundreds of
them are rushing off in the same
direction
meanwhile the UA students themselves are
also there including class 1a major
dejado and some others that I don't
think I've seen before they are all
being led by burnin one of endeavor
sidekicks in an effort to evacuate the
residents of a certain mountain town as
the heroes prepared to do something
important at the foot of the mountain
this is where the chapter ends and boy
oh boy are we ever heading into a
massive war arc an arc that will involve
all of our favorite pro heroes and UA
students and of course all of our
favorite villains I mean the fact that
the laundry hero wash is involved means
that it's really about to go down the
laundry here all doesn't mess around
seriously though I think I know why the
previous chapter told us that all of the
heroes have disappeared from the city
and I also think that Hawks might
currently be in serious life-threatening
danger remember how earlier in chapter 2
v 8 twice casually told Hawks that
shigaraki was powering up in the
mountains of Kyoto and that it would
take four months this is some really
specific and important
nation that twice just casually revealed
to Hawks
Hawks was clearly extremely worried
about what would happen if the
paranormal Liberation Front made the
first move so it is highly likely that
as soon as he got the big reveal about
shigaraki from twice Hawks immediately
informed the Public Safety Commission
president about the Intel that he
received the big pro hero gathering that
we saw at the end of the chapter is
probably an attempt to find shigaraki
and capture him before he can finish
powering up and so this raid is most
likely taking place in the mountains of
Kyoto because we see from the imagery of
the town that it is located right next
to some kind of mountain range the raid
is so serious and important that even
the students are being involved although
the students have been given the task of
laying back and evacuating all the
innocent civilians who live inside the
town keeping the students back makes
sense since they are so young and
inexperienced but the very fact that
they were involved in the first place
meaning that they are being put in
danger means that this is a very serious
situation there's just one problem this
whole thing could be one big deadly trap
in my previous MHA video I said that a
possible reason why all the heroes may
have vanished from the city is because
they were lured away by Yugi Coe and the
villains so that the villains could do
something big inside the city itself
that is why Yugi Coe decided to make a
public appearance in the hospital at
that exact time even though we know that
his appearances at the hospital are rare
and that could also be why Yugi Coe
appears to be in such a good mood when
he does make that mysterious unannounced
visit to the City Hospital but beyond
just Yugi Coe I think that twice may
have suspicions about Hawkes twice may
suspect that Hawkes is actually a spy we
saw that twice directly questioned why
Hawkes sympathizes with the Liberation
Front even though he is a hero Hawks had
a quick answer for him an answer related
to the freedom to do whatever he wants
to do and fly free but does twice really
buy that answer twice also says a few
times that Hawks is a nice guy and can't
possibly be a bad guy
maybe he says that one too many times
and let's not forget that twice was
right there with Hawkes when Hawkes
received the coded message about the
hospital back in Chapter two five five
hawks tried to play it off as just
another pro-hero gig that he couldn't be
bothered with but perhaps twice realized
that something was off I know this isn't
clear evidence that twice espect hawks
of being a spy but if the Liberation
Front does suspect Hawkes then perhaps
twice as casual reveal about where she
Guara he is and what he is doing was
intended to set a trap for hawks and the
heroes twice reveals that she Guara key
is in the mountains of Kyoto and that he
will be there for four months while he
is powering up Hawks who is already
nervous about the liberation fronts
power decides to give that information
over to the heroes so that they can
strike before she gerak he becomes even
stronger but since we know that she
Caracas procedure was successfully
completed we saw huge eco celebrating
that shigaraki was his masterpiece and
since we also know that
huija Co was in a good mood at the
hospital after the three-month time-skip
it seems that the hero raid must not
have succeeded and instead would you co
got exactly what he wanted this could be
because Hawkes was deliberately fed
false information by twice and led
straight into a trap after all the
mountains of Kyoto are very close
geographically to where Dacus city was
located before it was destroyed the same
city that was controlled by Reid estro
and the paranormal Liberation Army so if
I'm onto something here and the heroes
were lured into a trap set by huge
Akashi gawky and the other villains then
that would explain why in late March the
heroes had vanished from the city they
were all mobilized because of hawks is
info Badshah Karachi and then they were
lured into a trap in the mountains of
Kyoto so what happens to them now
obviously all those heroes and students
won't die this is a shown in series
after all but the big question is what
will happen to them now and what is
Fujiko going to
why did he decide to make a rare public
appearance at this exact time at the
very same time that the heroes have
vanished we will have to wait until the
coming chapters to find out exactly what
is going on but one thing is clear this
is the biggest and most epic war arc in
the history of boku no hero this is
definitely the most important and most
hype arc yet and we can expect some
major things to go down including epic
battles shocking betrayals and probably
some tragic deaths as well although as
long as my boy the laundry hero washer
survives I'll be good Shigure Aki and
the paranormal Liberation Army are
stronger than ever strong enough to make
Hawks seriously worried even before she
Guara keys latest powerup and Yugi Co is
clearly up to something big meanwhile
many of the heroes are also at the top
of their game in this very moment and
the students including Bakugan and Deku
have been getting exponentially stronger
so both sides have a lot of firepower
behind them this is the best time for
both sides to go a head to head in an
absolutely epic war arc this arc is
going to be completely crazy and I can't
wait to see what happens next let me
know what you guys think we're all those
heroes just led into a deadly trap by og
ko shigaraki and the paranormal
Liberation Front
also what is Fujiko planning to do
inside the hospital now that the heroes
are far away from the city and don't get
me started on shigaraki what kind of
overpowered monster is he about to
become don't forget to hit me up with
your feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications if you
don't want YouTube to bury our videos
you really have to go through the
trouble of clicking the bell and then
selecting the option that says all you
can also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar and a big
thank you to all of our anime
or patrons for making videos like this
one possible with all the YouTube
problems lately patron support is more
important than ever so thank you guys so
much
special thanks to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous fitted ala beat Anatole
kazansky alpha deal on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney and Emperor otaku and I
can't forget the ones that rise above
all other clans a massive thank you to
all of our the wanna tear patrons
including in grata a Lola nada
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson Queenie no if you enjoy
our work and you feel that it provides
value to you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear on our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]